ça s'est bien passé c'était lundi le 11
c'était un césairienne pis ça ça tu es
passé on est vraiment vraiment ce jeune
couple de parents prennent leur pour la
première fois en un mois depuis la
mi-avril en raison d'une fin de
grossesse difficile
ils étaient confinés dans leur chambre
une culture un mois c'est long dans un
hôpital en pleine pandémie
même si tout le personnel fait son
possible nate étage était vraiment bon
tous les ferments prédateur avait une
masse qui les dégâts donc ce test est
correct mais c'est toujours notre note
est quelqu'un qui rentre à ce que son
nom depuis le début de l'épidémie il ya
plus de 220 accouchements au cusm les
cas simples écho très complexe peu
importe les circonstances il faut
soigner toutes les mères non un état un
centre d'excellence
on doit accoucher les mamans positives
ou négatives les règles de base port du
masque et des gants tout un des
infections régulière et les grands
moyens pour les quatre qu'ovide
également une nouvelle contrainte pas
plus de visiteurs et aucun droit de
sortie on reste quand même sensible à
l'effet qu'on veut que l'expérience se
fasse de façon professionnelle mais
aussi avec l'empathie de la compassion
avec nos clientèles heureusement pour
les femmes enceintes jusqu'ici la cuvée
2009 ne représente pas une grande menace
pour elle rien à voir avec le strass et
le h1n1 par exemple en fait pour une
femme enceinte le risque d'être infecté
par le corona virus est identique à
celui de toute autre femme de son âge
même chose pour les complications
sévères qui sont rares quant au risque
d'accouchement prématuré ou deux mortels
t il semble aussi très bas mais il n'est
pas nul pour autant on a plusieurs cas
de décès pendant la grossesse est dans
la période juste après la grossesse qui
ont été rapportés dans plusieurs
endroits dans le monde donc on sait que
la femme enceinte n'est pas épargné
malheureusement des manifestations
sévère et de la mortalité causée par la
coved
autre bonne nouvelle des études
préliminaires laissent
roy que le virus ne peut pas se
transmettre de la mère à l'enfant durant
la grossesse seulement durant ou après
l'accouchement et aussi le fait le lait
maternel ne représente pas un risque
pour l'enfant ça c'est rassurant le
virus ne sommes pas se transmettre par
le lait lui même
par contre lors de l'allaitement la
maman porte le bébé tout de même proche
d'elle donc il y à une transmission
possible pendant l'allaitement mais pas
par le lait on va être correct mais il
faut qu'on s'habitue de toujours avoir
dans masse minogue et quand on sort en
sortant de l'hôpital le jeune couple
savait déjà ce qu'il attendait lakovic
19 c'est leur nouvelle réalité
quotidienne
mais il faisait beau chaud et le petit
miracle s'est produit
et ça c'est spencer les boudins singly
exact ouais mais elle est pas refaire
ici norma grondin radio canada montréal